في ظل المخاوف من تخطي سكان العالم 8
مليارات نسمه وما اذا كانت موارد الارض
ستكفي هذه الاعداد من البشر دراسه تثير
قلقا من الجانب الاخر مستقبل البشريه في
خطر والسبب الانخفاض المتسارع في تركيز
الحيوانات المنويه وخصوبه الرجل المتراجع
الدراسه التي نشرت في مجله هيومن
ريبرودكشن ابليت تقول ان عدد الحيوانات
المنويه انخفض بحوالي اثنين وخمسين في
المئه في جميع انحاء العالم بين عامي 1973
و2018 الازمه ان نسبه التراجع السنويه
تزداد بمقدار حيث وصلت الى اثنين فاصل 64%
بعد عام 2020
بحسب الباحثين السمنه تناول الاطعمه
المصنعه وقله النشاط البدني من العوامل
المؤثره بشكل مباشر على تراجع الخصوبه عند
الذكور
[موسيقى]
هل بالفعل طبيا نشهد تراجع في خصوبه
الرجال بالنسبه تفوق ال 50%
في خطر بس الموضوع ملفت جدا
وبيستاهل انه واحد يتوقف عنده لانه
الدراسات يلي عم تتيلا يعني مش هي دراسه
واحده
معين الا انخفاض الخصوبه مع الوقت
نتوقف عنده ونقول لك في مشكله ونحاول لي
الى حل دكتور ميشيل بس في يعني تناقض
اليوم من اسبوع اعلنا انه البشريه وصلت
لثمانيه مليار في ذات الوقت بنقول في
مشاكل خصوبه عند الرجل كيف نفهم هل
المفارقه طبعا
35 40 سنه هلا معدل عامل الانسان
اذا الوفيات عن متقل هلا الولدات عمت تكثر
او تقل بحسب البلدان يعني بنلاقي فيه
بلدين نسبه الخصوبه فيها كثير مرتفعه وهن
همم البلدان يا اللي هي تعتبر العالم
الثالث غير المتقدمه في الوقت اللي فيه
البلدان المتقدمه عملاء نسبه الخصوبه فيها
حتى عم تسير مايونيز يعني عم تتراجع الى
الورق طيب دكتور هناك من يرجع الاسباب الى
المواد كيماويه التعرض للاطعمه الفائقه
المعالجه السمنه التدخين لكل الرجال اللي
عم بيشوفونا ما هي نصائح همم تنصحهم فيها
حتى يعني همم حافظوا على صحتهم
لك اول سبب اذا بدنا نكون واقعيين هو
التقدم في العمر عند الزواج يعني هذا
السبب الرئيسي ليش هلا الخصوبه هي اقل من
ما كانت عليها بالماضي يعني اذا انا اقول
ان احنا واحد من ثمانيه كابلز هلا بعصرنا
الحالي بواجه مشكله في الانجاب واحد على
ثمانيه تقريبا
اذا في عندنا تطور ملفت بنسبه همم
همم العمر مثل ما قلت يعني احنا الرجل اول
المراه هني بيكونوا بعز الخصوصي تبعيتهم
بعمر العشرين مين بقى بيجوز بعمر 20 سو
الموضوع عم يصير في الزواج بعمره متقدم
اكثر كل ما نتقدم بالعمر كل ما تخف قدرت
الخصوبه هلا السبب الاخر الاساسي او نسميه
الانفايرمنت لتوكسينز او التلوث المجتمع
يعني احنا الحضاره تعادل تلوث نحن كل شيء
عني بنشوفه من معامل من من
تكنولوجي كل هذا بيؤدي الارتفاع في نسبه
التلوث